thousands of pigs on a Dutch Farm meet
intended for the Spanish Market but
after nearly 20 years Annette Martin's
and her husband have decided to stop
soon they will sell all their livestock
our nitrogen emissions are extremely
high and our business needs a lot of
renovation we need new Stables because
these are outdated but if the bank sees
that our emissions are so high they
don't want to support us any longer so
we had no choice but to stop the farm
lies next to a nature reserve that is
protected under European law now that
the EU has approved the government's
buyout plan the family hopes to receive
generous compensation in recent years
thousands of farmers have protested
against proposals to drastically cut
emissions more than 50 000 Dutch Farmers
keep more than 11 million pigs and
nearly 4 million cows intense and highly
productive farming has turned the
Netherlands into one of the world's main
food producers but the farm like this
could soon be a thing of the past while
farmers are now being pressured into
selling their animals and find another
profession others insist they'll
continue
in a few years Dairy Farmer Jan van
Levin wants to hand over his hurt to his
son he says the government should invest
more in technology that reduces
emissions from animal waste
Farmers have done a lot for this country
but the government doesn't seem to
realize this the minister talking about
hugely attractive buyout packages that's
a ridiculous statement Greenpeace says
compensating Farmers on a voluntary
basis won't lead to a big enough
reduction in nitrogen
the government should force Farmers to
stop it has to happen now and it will be
painful Farmers have to be told you will
need to quit and we will withdraw your
license we will compensate you but you
have to stop why should they this is
their life it's like they are criminals
it's like they are doing something bad
they produce food except for water and
oxygen we need food but damage the
nature at the same time no no that's
that's that's just that's that's
bull crap I would say Caroline
vanderplas has grown into a political
force to be reckoned with after her
former citizens movement became the
largest party in all Dutch provinces
during elections in March while she
supports compensating farmers who want
to quit her party is firmly against
stricter measures possibly delaying
government plans to half nitrogen
emissions by 2030. stefans and Al
Jazeera in wildenberg the Netherlands
researchers in Zambia have built a